[Musica]
per raggiungere dei risultati in
qualsiasi ambito della vita è necessario
cambiare il cambiamento infatti è alla
base della storia che vi racconterò oggi
c'è la storia della mia vita
tendenzialmente sono sempre stata una
persona molto introverso fatto vari
speech ma sembra per la parlato in
maniera tecnica del mondo dei social e
questa è la prima volta che in qualche
modo parlo di me e della mia esperienza
e per farlo ho deciso di farli insomma
su un palco importante come questo e vi
giuro che non mi hanno pagato per dirlo
qual è il mio più grande risotto
raggiunto no non sono stato sulla luna
non ho trovato la cura di qualche
malattia hanno fatto niente di tutto
questo
io ho creato una pagina di meme il mio
più grande iri stato raggiunto infatti è
aver creato il progetto di legal highs
per chi non lo conoscesse le goalies è
una pagina umoristica nella quale
creiamo delle vignette in quegli omini
lego per non tra di loro creando
situazioni divertenti battute e
attualmente insomma abbiamo raggiunto
risultati veramente interessanti intanto
che tra le varie piattaforme sui vari
social abbiamo non community di app di
quasi 2 milioni di utenti quindi un
sacco di persone sono interessate al
nostro progetto voglio sottolineare
inoltre che il successo del progetto non
è solamente merito mio sono con altri
due ragazzi che insomma creiamo i
contenuti lavoriamo tutto quanto che
sono pietre samuel insomma che che
saluto
però oggi non sono qui per parlare di
legal highs o almeno non solo di questo
ma di tutto il percorso per tutto il
la strada che ho seguito ricca di
cambiamenti che mi ha permesso di
raggiungere questi risultati
e alla fine di diventare anche la
persona che sono adesso
nella mia vita ho sempre avuto due modi
diversi di vedere le cose o bianco o
nero da una parte ci sono le cose che
non mi piacciono per queste cose proprio
non riesco a impegnarmi e non di
conseguenza non ci dedico nessuno sforzo
questo è stato l'esempio della scuola
non della scuola in generale ma del
percorso di studi che ho scelto alle
superiori che era informatica e mi ha
riscritto con il mito di esser ad affari
informatica probabilmente giocherò che i
videogame suo giorno grande bugia non è
stato assolutamente così mi sono
ritrovato in una scuola nella quale le
materie di indirizzo non mi piacevano mi
prendevano e di conseguenza ci dedica o
veramente pochissimo impegno e non di
poco sforzo diciamo tanto che ho anche
perso un anno tra le varie cose e questo
è stato il primo approccio dall'altra
parte e ci sono le cose che mi piacciono
per queste cose veramente ci dedico
tutte le mie energie mi sveglio la
mattina con un obiettivo e trovo che sia
anche uno dei motivi per cui valga
veramente la pena vivere la vita e
svegliarsi con un sogno da raggiungere
con cous qualcosa che ti piace e che ha
qui dedichi veramente tutte le tue
energie ogni giorno nel mio caso ho
trovato questa valvola di sfogo nel
portare della leggerezza sui social
creando appunto contenuti divertenti
ed è proprio questo il motivo
la causa che c'è dietro insomma il
nostro successo sui social fatto di di
fare qualcosa che ci piace quindi grazie
a questa passione appunto che ci spinge
a creare contenuti ogni giorno stiamo
raggiungendo questi risultati
in generale questo dualismo questo
vedere le cose o in bianco o in nero in
qualche modo mi ha spesso spinto a
cambiare quello che stessi facendo in
quel momento quindi cambiare
completamente dove mi trovavo che fosse
studio o lavoro insomma ecco magari
adesso so già che stretti immaginando
una persona che si sveglia da un giorno
all'altro e ti visualizza non ti
risponde su whatsapp non intendo
assolutamente questo semplicemente sì mi
trovo in una situazione in cui non mi
trovo a mio agio
faccio di tutto per trovare la posizione
più giusta per me per questo non ho
appena finito le scuole superiori e
insomma avevo tutti i miei compagni che
in qualche modo avevano già la strada
delineata verso studi di informatico di
ingegneria
e io che ho visto solamente quelle
materie e non mi piacevano non sapevo
che cosa fare della mia vita quindi
insomma con l'idea di non perdere
ulteriore tempo e soprattutto con mia
madre che mi diceva fai qualcosa della
tua vita
ho deciso di buttarmi subito nel mondo
del lavoro
qui c'è stato il primo cambiamento
importante della mia vita in questo caso
è stato anche piuttosto drastico
infatti dopo pochi mesi mi sono
ritrovato in uno studio commercialista e
a inserire le fatture a gestire la
contabilità di vari aziende quindi una
cosa molto diversa rispetto a quello che
faccio adesso per me era un mondo
completamente nuovo
oltre anche se la mia prima esperienza
lavorativa devo dire che i colleghi in
generale hanno tutti abbastanza gentili
e disponibili con me
solo che in qualche modo a punto avevo
cambiato completamente quello che stavo
facendo in quel periodo e il cambiato
anche piuttosto repentina molto veloce e
devo dire la verità di pensare in questo
momento alle fatture agli 730 gli f24 mi
vengono ancora i brividi la situazione
in qualsiasi caso non era così
spiacevole però il tempo stesso sentivo
che mi mancava qualcosa sentivo che ero
limitato e quindi in qualche modo mi
sentivo un po al limite facendo un passo
indietro guardando il mio passato sono
sempre stata una persona molto creativa
fin da quando frequentavo la scuola e
scuole medie e avevo vari progetti con i
miei amici coi miei compagni di classe
in cui creavamo dei contenuti
distribuiti appunto sui vari social
sulle varie piattaforme quindi in
qualche modo questa cosa ce l'ho sempre
avuto un po nel dna e un altro chiaro
segnale di creatività ce l'ho avuto alle
scuole superiori quando preferì vari
schemi evidenziare piuttosto di studiare
effettivamente parte gli scherzi la vena
creativa in qualche modo è sempre stato
una costante nella mia vita quindi a
stare nell'ufficio commercialista
inserire per 8 ore delle fatture nel nel
computer
era una situazione che mi stava molto
stesso dar molto stretto avevo bisogno
di una valvola di sfogo da questa
necessità è nato le goalies dopo lodi 1
fisso infatti e tornavo a casa insieme
al resto del team che avevamo un sacco
di contenuti ci dedicavamo anima e cuore
a proprio al progetto è ovviamente un
tour de force incredibile perché le ore
che dedicavamo insomma tutto quanto
erano tantissime però la soddisfazione
di vedere nascere e crescere un progetto
di questo tipo sicuramente era uno degli
stimoli uno dei motivi che ci faceva
andare avanti
analizzando un attimo il progetto le
goalies nasce con l'obiettivo di portare
anche in maniera innovativa della
leggerezza nel mondo dei social ma anche
prima ho detto leggerezza con leggerezza
non intendo superficialità infatti
spesso e i temi che trattiamo ok possono
essere prese in maniera ironica
riverente da volte anche provocatoria
però sono spesso molto
attinente un tema e delle volte anche
profondi non sempre ecco però delle
volte anche profondi
queste caratteristiche uniche hanno
permesso al progetto di raggiungere
veramente numeri importanti nel giro di
poco tempo e al tempo stesso vedendo
crescere questi numeri è nata in me è
nato all'interno del team la necessità
di avere più consapevolezza di quello
che stavamo facendo perché ovviamente
muovendo tanti numeri si raggiungono
tante persone quindi bisogna sapere come
comunicare oltre al fatto che insomma
ora dobbiamo stare attenti perché con i
numeri che muoviamo quotidianamente
invadere san marino sarebbe un gioco da
ragazzi
dunque per acquisire questa
consapevolezza è un po alla volta mi
sono avvicinato al mondo del marketing e
della comunicazione
mi sono reso conto di quanto comunica in
maniera corretta sia un elemento
fondamentale al giorno d'oggi per
qualsiasi tipo di progetto digitale per
questo ho spostato il mio focus appunto
verso il mondo del marketing della
comunicazione
ho fatto diversi corsi ho studiato in
maniera da autodidatta e tra cui anche
appunto un corso che ho fatto a milano
io sono di venezia insomma si sentirà
dall'accento e ho fatto un corso a
milano e faceva ogni weekend su e giù
fossero spola tra venezia e milano
diventando effettivamente il
finanziatore numero uno dei servizi
ferroviari italiani questa esperienza in
qualche modo mi ha fatto capire che la
strada era quella giusta e mi piaceva al
marketing tacevano le materie così ha
inizio 2020 ho mollato il lavoro dal
commercialista dopo oltre quattro anni
che era nello studio e lavoro all'atto
punto perché volevo dedicarmi a tempo
pieno al progetto sia di legal highs sia
di formazione mia nel mondo del
marketing quindi
tra le altre cose mi ri scritto anche un
corso che dovevo fare a los angeles
verso marzo 2020 dopo sappiamo come sono
andate le cose io mi ero organizzato
pesi biglietti avevo preso l'alloggio
tutto quanto e poi boom la pandemia
mi son ritrovato senza un lavoro e con
un sogno svanito in pochissimo tempo per
che dall'oggi al domani insomma chi ha
sky ex se lo aspettava quindi in qualche
modo dovuto reinventarmi anche qui c'è
stato un nuovo cambiamento importante al
tempo stesso è cosa abbiamo deciso di
fare la gente in quel periodo era a casa
c'era lockdown quindi anche noi con il
progetto abbiamo deciso di spingere
sull'acceleratore abbiamo creato sempre
più contenuti cercano di coinvolgere
sempre di più la nostra community e di
conseguenza anche i numeri delle persone
che ci seguivano e che interagivano con
i nostri contenuti appunto sono
diventati sempre più grandi
tanto che insomma
numeri crescono e di conseguenza molte
aziende si sono interessate al nostro
progetto perché volevano comunicare
volevano raccontarsi all'interno delle
nostre veniente raccontando appunto la
propria realtà e il proprio business
all'interno della nord delle nostre
vignette ad oggi questo è il nostro
lavoro perché appunto collaboriamo con
tante tante agenzie tante aziende e
quindi ci guadagniamo da questo tipo di
attività facendo a tutti gli effetti
dell'attività di influencer marketing e
riuscendo a vivere di questo anche se
devo dire la verità i miei parenti devo
ancora capire cosa faccia effettivamente
per vivere
dal punto di vista personale in qualche
modo e sto replicando quello che faccio
con le goalies con altre con altre
aziende ha fatto in pratica il
consulente in cui e replico le strategie
che abbiamo applicato su leggo live con
queste aziende che vogliono raccontarsi
in maniera magari anche innovativa in
maniera di drafting per usare un
inglesismo e quindi applico tutto ciò
che è stato imparato durante questo
progetto
sicuramente uno degli stimoli che ci
spinge andare avanti è il fatto che
riceviamo tantissimi complimenti da
parte della nostra community che
apprezza il nostro lavoro e alcune volte
riceviamo anche dei messaggi che ogni
volta mi spezzano il cuore di persone
che dicono che in qualche modo siamo
riusciti a migliorare un loro periodo
difficile appunto grazie a questa
leggerezza si tratta precedentemente
con il cambiamento con la
sperimentazione di cose nuove e cercando
di non fossilizzarmi troppo negli stessi
posti nelle stesse situazioni sono
riuscito a fare tante esperienze che in
qualche modo ognuna di esse ha aggiunto
un mattoncino per rendermi la
costruzione che sono adesso giusto per
rimanere un po in tema con le goalies
concludo dicendo che lo so durante
questo discorso
ho detto un sacco di volte la parola
cambiamento questo perché come dicevo in
apertura
ritengo che il cambiamento sia
l'elemento imprescindibile per
raggiungere i propri risultati e perché
no anche i propri sogni
grazie
[Applauso]